hola de nuevo en esta ocasión vamos a
ver la regla del cociente la regla del
cociente es otra de nuestras reglas que
vamos a ocupar para derivar entonces
vamos a verlo con un ejemplo de una vez
supongamos que tengo la derivada con
respecto a x de quien pues me voy a
tomar de x elevado al cubo ya esto le
voy a quitar 5 veces x a la quinta y
todo esto lo voy a elevar a la potencia
3 me parece la potencia 3 una buena
potencia y ojo lo voy a dividir esto a
su vez lo voy a dividir entre 2 veces x
+ 5 y todo esto elevado a la potencia 5
ok yo quiero la derivada de todo lo que
está dentro de mi paréntesis gigante es
decir de la división de funciones y
seguramente ustedes no van a decir oye
sal no tengo ni idea de cómo se hace eso
nunca hemos visto un ejercicio como éste
como no los puedes poner pero al menos
en este primer ejercicio voy a hacer un
poquito de trampa y vamos a ver esto con
la regla del producto
para que tengan una idea hay una noción
de la división primero quiero analizarlo
con la regla del producto entonces a lo
que se me ocurre ser es como son un
patrimonio entre un polinomio voy a
pasar el segundo polinomio que está
dividiendo para arriba como lo voy a
pasar pues bueno primero voy a poner x
cúbica menos 5 x a la quinta y todo esto
al cubo y lo voy a pasar multiplicando
pero con potencia negativa es decir 2 x
5 elevado a la menos 5 y esto es por las
leyes los exponentes esto ya lo habíamos
visto la potencia negativa es pura
álgebra elemental entonces ahora si
calculemos la derivada de esta expresión
esto es por la regla de la cadena tengo
que calcular la derivada dentro que es
3x cuadrada menos 25 x cuarta paréntesis
y todo esto lo tengo que multiplicar por
la derivada de la función grande es
decir bajo el exponente 3 pongo la
función tal cual x cúbica menos 5 x
quinta y le bajó 1 el exponente es decir
al cuadrado muy bien y esto hay que
multiplicarlo por la otra función sin
derivar estoy utilizando la regla del
producto
2 x 5 elevado a la menos 5 y bueno hasta
aquí vamos en la mitad de la derivada
como vimos en el vídeo pasado hay que
aumentarle la derivada de la segunda
función pero que es la derivada de 2 x 5
elevada a la menos 5 pues bueno primero
hay que derivar los de adentro que pues
es más fácil solamente es dos porque el
58 derivada de 0 bajamos el exponente
menos 5 ponemos un paréntesis y en el
paréntesis recuerden que ponemos la
función tal cual sin derivar es decir
ponemos 2 x + 5 y esto le va a dar a la
menos 5 menos 1 o sea la menos 6 muy
bien y todo esto hay que multiplicarlo
por x cúbica menos 5 x quinta y todo
esto elevado a la 3 muy bien y ya con
esto acabamos la derivada por la regla
del producto utilizando la regla de la
cadena y esta derivada por la regla del
producto nos sirvió esta vez para ver la
regla del cociente si tienen un
polinomio elevado una potencia pues la
potencia la subimos por delante de los
exponentes y la subimos como una
potencia negativa yo utilizamos la regla
del producto
muy bien ahora vamos a ver algunas
derivadas distintas vamos a ver
derivadas de funciones aunque no sean
polinomios vamos a agarrar derivadas
exponenciales de logaritmos pero ahorita
lo vamos a ver y con esto voy a seguir
con la idea de la regla del del cociente
muchas estas fórmulas que vamos a ver
ahorita en las derivadas aparecen en tus
libros de texto y son derivadas muy
importantes en algunos de los vídeos
posteriores probaré muchas de estas
fórmulas pero ahorita solamente voy a
poner las fórmulas tal cual entonces la
primera dice que la derivada de la x es
y es algo sorprendente y es que este
número es igual a 2.7 18 blah blah blah
blah blah aparece en todo tipo de
lugares locos las matemáticas y además
tienen las propiedades muy extravagante
es de hecho una de estas propiedades más
extrañas es la que les voy a mencionar
la derivada de la x es ni más ni menos
que a la equis dicho de otra manera la
derivada de la x es ella misma y es la
única función que cumple esta propiedad
y yo sé que esta información te puede
dejar
un poco perplejo y pasmado pero es que
sorprendente pero vamos a verlo mejor
con un caso particular supongamos que yo
tengo fx igual a pues era la equis
estamos analizando ya la equis y yo
calculo efe de dos pues esto es cuadrado
muy bien y si yo te pregunto oye amigo
de un 2 es un hombre pero hoy amigo cuál
es la derivada o la pendiente de la
recta tangente en este punto de esta
función en el punto 2 cuadrada pues tú
me vas a responder sal la pendiente es
cuadrada y es que esta propiedad hace
que mi mente gire muy rápido porque si
nosotros decimos esta función
quiero saber cuál es la pendiente de la
recta tangente en algún punto pues es ni
más ni menos que la función evaluada en
ese punto y es que el número aparece en
muchas partes y las matemáticas aparece
también las aplicaciones para las
matemáticas de hecho algún día voy a
hacer un vídeo que diga la magia del
número e pero bueno por hábito no quiero
seguir trabajando mucho en el número y
voy a seguir con mis fórmulas las
derivadas bueno
a continuación os voy a enseñar la
segunda derivada más sorprendente que
hay la derivada con respecto a x del
logaritmo natural de x es decir del
logaritmo en base espero que se acuerden
de sus clases de logaritmos la derivada
del logaritmo natural de x es
1 / x también es esta sorprendente esto
también me deja perplejo es que fíjense
voy a agarrar algunas de funciones las
voy a dibujar y voy a dibujar también
sus derivadas por ejemplo voy a tomar x
a la menos 3 que por la regla del
exponente pues bajamos el exponente me
queda menos 3 x a la menos 3 - 1 - 4
bien ahora tenemos x al menos 2 pues
bajamos el exponente menos 2 x a la
menos 3 muy bien ahora derivemos
1 - x al menos 1 más bien uno más y esto
me va a quedar menos x a la menos 2 muy
bien y ahora voy a derivar x a la 0 pero
x a la 0 por las propiedades de los
exponentes siempre es 1 y la derivada
una constante siempre 0 entonces pues la
derivada de uno es cero la derivada de x
0 es 0 y de x por su derivada es uno y
dgs cuadrada es 2x hasta aquí vamos
viendo bien pero todas las potencias de
x cumplen este patrón por ejemplo es x a
la menos 4 y después es algo con x a la
menos 3
hago con x menos 2 y después dónde está
el x menos 1 porque después de que el 0
el 1 el x el x cuadrada aquí falta el x
a la menos 1 dónde está mi x al menos 1
es decir que funciona al derivar la nos
da x el a menos 1 esto es muy extraño
para mí porque a donde se fue el x a la
menos uno y la respuesta es es el
logaritmo natural de x hay veces que me
voy a la cama todavía pensando en esto
para mí me parece extraordinario de
hecho yo creo que en algún momento voy a
hacer un vídeo que diga por qué la
derivada del logaritmo natural de x es 1
/ x pero bueno entonces tenemos que la
derivada de ea la x es la equis y la
derivada del organismo natural de x es 1
/ x puedes si quieres memorizarlo pero
lo que sí sé es que en los siguientes
vídeos voy a utilizar las derivadas de
estas funciones con regla de la cadena y
regla del producto y regla del cociente
en fin pero vamos a ver ahora otros
tipos de derivadas otras derivadas que
van a ser importantes que memoricen las
derivadas de funciones trigonométricas y
estas son muy sencillas realmente no
tienen mucho problema
por ejemplo la derivada con respecto a x
del seno de x bueno pues la derivada del
seno es el con seno de x es muy fácil
esto la derivada del seno de x es el
coseno de x creo que en algún punto voy
a hacer un vídeo de por qué salen estas
fórmulas pero bueno la siguiente
derivada la derivada con respecto x del
coseno de x esto es igual al menos seno
de x deberían memorizar las realmente si
las memorizar en un examen pueden
utilizarlas de una manera muy rápida y
bueno la siguiente la derivada de con
respecto a x la tangente de x es uno
entre el consejo cuadra donde x o dicho
de otra manera esto es lo mismo que la
secante cuadrada de x espero realmente
que haya algo en sus adentros que se
mueva muy rápidamente y los incite a
comprobar que realmente estas son las
derivadas o más aún que la recta
tangente la pendiente de la recta
tangente del seno por ejemplo es el cose
no podrían hacer la gráfica del seno en
el mismo plano junto con la gráfica del
coseno y entender realmente la forma
intuitiva de por qué la derivada
describe la recta tangente la pendiente
de la
tangente de la función original pero ya
casi nos acaba el tiempo así que les voy
a recomendar que se aprendan todas estas
fórmulas debido a que en los siguientes
vídeos las voy a mezclar y además voy a
utilizar la regla de la cadena la regla
del cociente la regla del producto y
todo esto para hacer unas derivadas muy
extravagantes unas derivadas muy
difíciles pero no más difíciles de las
que van a ver en sus exámenes o en sus
ejercicios por lo pronto nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo